Speaker 1: Donald Trump is now apparently
turning not only on Fox News but also on Newsmax.
Donald Trump appeared on Newsmax last night
and he said the election is stolen and Fox
News no longer talks about it and Newsmax
no longer talks about it.
He says, I guess that they're afraid and he
even says to the Newsmax host, I bet you guys
are going to cut what I'm saying right now.
And the host says, No, no, no, we're not going
to cut it.
Check this out.
Trump's furious with anyone who won't uncritically
repeat his baseless and false claims.
Check this out.
Speaker 2: Look at the dishonesty of this
committee, right?
They don't talk about any of the things that
refute January six.
They don't talk about the election numbers.
They don't analyze the election.
The people were there because the election
was rigged and stolen.
So what they should be doing is trying to
convince people that it wasn't.
You do that through analyzing the numbers.
They don't want to do that.
In fact, they don't even want to hear that.
And Fox doesn't put it on.
And by the way, you people don't put it on
either.
You're afraid of being sued or something.
I don't know.
Someday you'll have to explain that this is.
Speaker 1: Yeah, well, at a certain point,
you can only lie so much before you're potentially
in legal jeopardy.
That's true.
It is.
Everything Trump is saying isn't true.
Speaker 2: To that fact.
He'll probably cut what I'm saying, of course.
Now, I don't know.
Of course, this will be on wake up tomorrow
morning, sir.
Absolutely not.
Get it done.
Will not allow that.
Get it done fast before Christmas.
Okay, but Mike, cut it out and let's see.
I hope they put it on.
Yeah, but this was about a rigged and stolen
election.
Speaker 1: Now, that's not actually what the
committee is about.
Understand, when Trump says the committee
won't investigate this other thing, it's sort
of like saying this committee refuses to talk
about the rash of thefts of catalytic converters
from Priuses.
Well, okay, that's not the focus of the committee.
The thefts of catalytic converters also happen,
too, happens to be a real thing, whereas the
theft of the election is imaginary.
But it's not what the committee is there to
do.
Speaker 2: That millions and millions of people
felt is true.
Speaker 1: Right.
And of course, facts don't care about your
feelings.
But Trump continues to repeat.
People feel the election was stolen, people
feel it was stolen, and Fox News no longer
talks about it and Newsmax no longer talks
about it.
They talked about it for months.
They talk about it for months, and there's
nothing there.
Now, what Trump is really saying when he says
this is media outlets that are supposed to
be friendly to me aren't doing enough heavy
lifting on the lies that I am trying to perpetuate.
That's the translation for what Trump is saying
here.
Interestingly, Trump was also asked during
this interview about the allegations made
by Cassidy Hutchinson that he lunged at a
Secret Service agent and tried to commandeer
the vehicle.
Trump's explanation for why it's not true
is sort of that he's too fat to do the thing
he was accused of doing.
Listen carefully here.
Speaker 2: And they put her on and they don't
even confirm it with the Secret Service.
The Secret Service people in the car said
this didn't happen.
But but you don't even need that.
Speaker 1: Now, remember, they have not testified
under oath.
There is a report through the grapevine that
some Secret Service agent is willing to contradict
some of what Cassidy Hutchinson said.
None of it has actually happened yet, but
okay, let's continue.
Speaker 2: Who would do that?
I would I would grab a Secret Service person
by the throat.
I don't even know if it's possible.
Certainly not in the beast.
It's very hard.
Even in one of the SUVs, it's very hard for
another reason.
These guys lift £350 right out of the air.
Speaker 1: So when Trump says these guys lift
£350 and I don't what he's saying is he's
out of shape.
What he's saying is he's obese.
What he's saying is it would be a stupid thing
to do to try to do anything.
But Trump does stupid things all the time.
Narcissists overstate there are over they.
Over believe they are falsely confident in
all of their abilities, not only their intelligence,
but maybe also their physical abilities.
And by the way, notice that what was said
there, the beast versus SUVs, initially the
claim was in the beast, meaning the presidential
limo.
Trump is sitting so far from the driver that
he couldn't do the thing Cassidy Hutchinson
accused him of doing.
But when you look at the video of that day,
if I recall correctly, Trump is actually leaving
in an SUV.
It's a different vehicle completely.
So when Laura Ingraham and others say you
can't do that in the limo, the video seems
to show Trump in an SUV.
All right.
Let's look at the last bit of this tonight.
Speaker 3: It seemed like it was pretty smooth.
Speaker 2: Yeah, no grabbing it.
It's fine, I.
But, you know, these are people.
These are great people.
They've devoted their lives to it.
And I think they were very embarrassed by
it because it makes them sound terrible.
Speaker 3: Tony Rinaudo and Bobby Engle were
great.
Speaker 2: I know their background.
Sterling is Sterling and it was very nice
that they came to my defense.
I thought it was incredible actually.
Speaker 1: Now remember, there are allegations
that they would come to Trump's defense.
They have not actually done it yet in any
kind of significant way because.
Speaker 2: You know, some whack job can say
this stuff and get away with it and other
things that I wanted guns at my rally.
Okay, now I'm speaking.
Why would I want guns?
I don't want people having standing with guns
in my rally.
Speaker 1: Oh, so guns are dangerous now.
Wow.
Okay.
I mean, if he believes guns everywhere make
everybody safer, why wouldn't he want the
gun?
It's all a verbal inkblot test.
But Trump now upset with Fox that they won't
do his carry water on his election lies upset
that Newsmax won't, even though they kind
of do, but just not to that degree.
And Trump essentially saying I'm not in shape
enough to do the thing that I was accused
of doing.
Make of it what you will.
We'll have these clips on our Instagram, which
you can find at David Pakman show.